et justement vous souhaitez réaliser
votre propre galette pour l'épiphanie
mais il vous manque ce petit truc qui la
rendra excellente nous avons la solution
nos journalistes sont allés à la
rencontre d'Hervé baudé sacré champion
de France de la meilleure galette des
rois aux amandes en 2023 le chef
pâtissier nous a même livré quelques
secrets pour impressionner vos invités
ce weekend Léa Turquier avec Roméo marm
après les fêtes de fin d'année c'est
bien sûr l'épiphanie je vais aujourd'hui
au délices de pierre à Château Renaud
pour apprendre tous les secrets pour
faire une bonne galette bon bien sûr je
vais mettre un peu la main à la patte
allez c'est
parti je suis avec Hervé baudé le
champion de France de la galette aux
amandes 2023 bonjour bonjour donc c'est
quoi le secret pour faire une bonne
galette aux amandes chez soi bah des
amandes amandes beur et donc on commence
par quoi pour faire une galette ah ben
on va commencer par faire une
franchipan là pour
sublimer la franipane du rhum 15 g de
rhum il faut mettre un tout petit peu
d'eau sur son pinceau ok pour humidifier
la galette voilà comme ça légèrement
donc là on va passer au garnissage nous
chez nous c'est vrai que c'est un peu
compliqué de faire une pâte feuilleté
soi-même est-ce qu'on peut l'cheter chez
son boulanger par exemple oui bien sûr
vous pouvez l'acheter chez votre
boulanger vous allez voir vot boulanger
vous lui commandez la veille pour le
[Musique]
lendemain une galette de de de 8
personnes nous mettons deux fes ok
pourquoi pour avoir plus de rois est-ce
que je peux les mettre ah mais bien sûr
allez-y comment où est-ce que je dois
les mettre plutôt centreord alors plus
au bord parce que quand vous allez
couper votre galette si vous tombez déjà
directement sur la fève c'est un peu
dommage ah c'est dommage et on vient
poser délicatement
dessus c'est parti pour la dorure alors
est-ce que je dois en mettre beaucoup
alors vous en mettez pas
trop là nous allons passer à l'étape du
rayage donc il faut prendre le centre de
la galette en lui faisant un tout petit
trou pour faire évacuer la vapeur
d'accord donc c'est une petite cheminée
voilà c'est ça exactement donc là faut
prendre ça lame de couteau et venir
faire des petits arrondis dessus en fait
ce qui est compliqué c'est la régularité
non c'est la régularité et puis la la
profondeur est-ce que là j'appuie trop
non là c'est parfait toujours non non
mais quand je dis que je j'allis vous
embaucher vous embouchez donc c'est
parti dans le four c'est parti au
four 45 minutes une température de 185°
environ et maintenant c'est l'étape du
sirop du sirop oui c'est pour vous
donner du brillance à Val le faire
sortir du four comme ça c'est le sirop
se finit de se consumer et bien se
coller au
feuilletage ah sur la f
voilà B là c'est le meilleur moment
voilà moment de savourer mer ro on sent
bien le r ouis mais ça reste léger c'est
vrai bon ben maintenant vous avez toutes
les astuces pour faire une bonne galette
chez vous en attendant moi je vais
continuer à me
[Musique]
régaler